but but i i want to i want to move it
back to you know what james was saying
james was saying we're optimistic or
he's optimistic i'm optimistic i take a
look at the declining ratings of these
institutions i take a look at we have
the story actually from the
post-millennial
red wave poll shows dramatic shift in
party preference from democrat to
republican at the end of 2021 so this is
from gallup one of the most credible
polling institutions so they say and we
can see that around the third quarter
there was a big decline in the shift
occurring and by quarter four of 21
republican sen identification outweigh
democrat by five points this is for the
first time in a couple like 20 years uh
maybe
there was a period i think in like
2010's where it was fairly even but we
haven't seen this pronounced of of
a flip since like 91. now i don't think
republicans are necessarily the answer i
think voting in the primaries and voting
for people care about this country is
the answer but the fact that people are
breaking away from the establishment
narratives from declining ratings to
party shift i think matters i think i
think it's it's grounds for optimism
right well i keep on plugging my book
but the second book you should reread
every year is 1984 which is the year i
was born
and in this book winston the win the
protagonist winston
says the party the party is a metaphor
for what we're talking about
tells you to reject the evidence of your
own eyes and ears
winston said it is the final most
essential commandment is the number one
rule don't trust your own eyes and ears
but the moment
propaganda becomes apparent
it loses its effect and i think what's
happening right now is people are
starting to wake up and they're and you
look i think you're right i think
they're losing like a what do you call
it a dog that was an animal that was
caged or something i like that metaphor
a trapped animal and i think this is
also why in 1984 they made them repeat
two plus two equals five because it's
nonsensical and they couldn't have
common sense they couldn't have rational
debate and discussion they needed to of
course obey this the state and the
controllers at all costs it's the
emanuel goldstein manual 1984 it
requires a moment-to-moment flexibility
in the treatment of facts so that scene
you're talking about where they're
torturing winston
you know two plus two equals is five and
winston's like spoiler alert for people
sorry
i said in case you haven't read it since
high school and he's like i don't
understand two plus two equals four and
it says and finally winston because he's
being tortured he says well two plus two
is whatever you want it to be exactly
but i feel like there are four lights i
feel like yes
this is america damn it this is america
and i think we're different than any
other country in the history of the
world
um i just don't think we're i'm hopeful
because i think people are understand
what's happening
what what the danger tim is that most
people are afraid
and that ma pension
mortgage
kids well
good luck to your kids because we don't
change this maybe your kids will be
holding bayonets or whatever the modern
equivalent of a bayonet will be so we
better give up our pensions
and our mortgages there's more to life
than my mortgage dude you got to blow
them but it's really you know it's it's
very difficult when you have so much to
lose what's the point of living what's
the point of living what's the point of
life
well well
this is the question what's the meaning
of play absolutely this is the question
i don't think there's an answer to what
is the meaning of life no no my my
questions
you posed a rhetorical question to me
and my answer i'm saying i rather i
posed a rhetorical question to you right
what's the point of life
if without meaning
you know the pursuit of happiness well
there's also the pursuit of meaning sure
and the excuse that we're giving is
for following orders there's 120 what
i'm saying is if you have people who
have a family and they have a home and
they want to protect those things right
they're going to go to great lengths to
protect those things they're not going
to give them up until they're forced to
if you can if you can get dinner on the
table and you can go to your job you're
going to do those things that's what
people do what if you're being asked to
do unconstitutional legal things well
then we see people start to start to
give those things up when they have to
but and that's you know but that's a
different point for everybody
when there is a you live in a house and
you're surrounded by a wooded area and
there is a fire on the horizon you have
people saying well
i think if we just sit around and do
nothing the fire eventually won't hit us
and we'll get lucky and it's like or you
can take action now get your family out
before the fire destroys your home
what we're seeing right now is that
people aren't going willing to go to
great lengths to protect their friends
and family or their or their children to
make sure there's food in the table
they're looking at short-term
gains and long-term losses so the reason
i use the forest fire uh analogy is that
this is like check off with the trees
it's off the distance okay the fire's
not here right why did the peasants i
know there's a fire i know there's a
fire i know it is destroying people's
homes i know my neighbors have lost
everything but i'll be fine i'm sure of
it right they think if they keep their
head down this is what's absolutely
describes in the google log archipelago
to survive at any price
and to survive at any price is the
danger because if you continue down this
road i like your analogy of long term
you're going to live in a lot in a
society which is permanently corrupted
where every where the lie becomes a
permanent form of existence and you have
to sell out your own family to not to
not you know go to the gulags james
speak when you're breaking rocks in the
gulags there's gonna be a guy 10 years
older and he's gonna go hey james ever
tell you about how my kid my kid played
soccer
and you're gonna be like oh yeah my
worst part about the gulags is the
inevitable hunger strike because i like
to eat
i get i get angry but there's a serious
point because i this is i want to go
back to this point which you and i
disagree with because this is the this
is the issue i'm not defending people
for for not wanting to fight i'm saying
people don't want to fight
right we're
not asking everybody so
this is a so this is my my martin luther
moment maybe we are at a breaking point
here yeah this is my martin luther
moment this is the issue at hand what
we're talking about nailing stuff on the
door that's it okay right now here i
stand i can do no other what we're
talking about you and i in this moment
that's everything i have people who have
families who who you know who are making
money for facebook pinterest they gave
it all up for the public's right to know
and they did so as a leap of faith and
the american people protected them
the hhs whistleblower jody she raised
half a million dollars after she gave up
her job for filming stuff in the
emergency room
zach at google eric cochran at pinterest
said i'll fall to ashes one day i want
my life to mean something after i'm gone
those are his words not mine sure i mean
i've you know like i lost everything
because i wrote the truth right right
this happened to me too and we need more
kind of thing happens to andy all the
time and we need more people yes we need
to speak up for that but we also need to
understand and not condemn the people i
think who who don't do it i think we
need to understand those people but we
should encourage them at the same time
as we understand them we should not
speak up but
at once because there's too many of us
to be destroyed their acquiescence their
compliance is literally leading us down
i'm sorry
i profoundly disagree with you there is
a
literally as i speak
thousands of dms every day what can i do
help me i want to help i want to i want
to i want to make a sacrifice
good good good so we need to we need to
create a mass movement of those people
we need to give them an opportunity to
fight people want to fight in this
country they don't know what to do they
want to do something um
but i i think with a hundred and twenty
thousand people the doj tim
there's gotta be one or two right i just
need one or two maybe i already have
them but
i need one or two more there's gotta be
okay we're following orders i get it you
have your mortgage to pay but
i don't know i i i i was like i was
watching this video i'm just saying
about clowns if we can be sympathetic to
those people i'm sorry
you're talking to a man who's been put
in handcuffs twice by the fbi for a
crime i didn't commit right and i would
like to believe that half the people in
my apartment actually were not bad
people at all i think they're very good
people i just think we're entering a
slippery slope
and we have to encourage people to do
the right thing and it will involve
without question it will involve
sacrifice and suffering it just will
not sound like dr peterson well the
police officers and fbi agents that are
right
i'm sitting next to a man who got thrown
concrete
milkshakes you know he got physical
physically assaulted for what he went
through my my only point was to have
empathy for the people who are terrified
of losing everything
how does that affect the actual actions
that we're going to take
how does empathy affect the actions that
we're going to do yes i don't think
condemning people gets them on your side
have i done that i didn't say that you
did okay
i i didn't i'm not i'm not condemning
anybody i mean we need to create a forum
for people to come forward we have to do
it yes we should all be encouraged we
should be encouraging each other to
speak the truth and to not be cowed by
this nonsense anymore i thoroughly agree
with you on that but the people
arresting james and the fbi agents that
went after him are making those excuses
we need to pay the mortgage we need to
pay the bills we need to make sure that
my uh you know kids are taken care of
those are the same kind of arguments
that i've heard made by corporate
journalists saying hey i just got to
read this script i just got to do what
they tell me to do because at the end of
the day i got to take care of myself
that's not what i'm defending but
there's a lot of people who use that
kind of justification even in the white
house you have to give up your pen
i was responding to you up i think point
zero zero one percent of people need to
give up their pension yes matt could you
imagine i think you're probably right
a thousand people in one of his
organizations just came out and said
we're willing to sacrifice our pensions
well then none of them would if every
single person at any of these corrupt
institutions if they all just said we
hereby all agree we have scruples and
won't do these illegal things yeah it
wouldn't happen in the first place i
agree with that
two choices you can follow your
conscience or you can and and then you
will lose your livelihood or you could
not follow your conscience and
have
a safe existence
my view you know on life growing up was
never based on tribalism and i think
that's that's what shapes my perspective
today is that there was no group
identified with there was nothing i saw
that said i need to be a part of it was
actually my whole life was if i don't
figure it out for myself i'm in trouble
yeah too many people today are wrapped
up in just trying to fit in with
whatever tribe they think will keep them
alive right we see with uh with ethan
klein he's the h3 podcast guy he he
deletes the jordan peterson interviews
such a that's such a trash move but it's
because in my opinion if you look at his
instagram he said youtube uh gave me a
strike i can't work for a week because
someone went to an old video and flagged
it and got it removed here's a guy who's
got a big he's got a company of 10
people he's got a 10 million subscribers
and because of the rule changes he's
getting banned so what does he do he
says i'm just going to adhere to
whatever they tell me to do yeah and he
deletes the job i'm going to say the 2
plus 2 equals 5 because i don't want the
rat to eat my face yeah exactly that's
what the or what was the genius
i mean room 101 room room 101.
i don't know what your psychological
version of the rat everyone's got their
fears but um this is a slippery slope
and i don't know i'm just quoting our
whistleblowers
that come to us
all of these people
it's not these are not my words they're
saying listen there's
i
want
my life to mean something and i guess it
is akin to what jordan peterson talks
about wasps
wasps yeah if if the establishment came
to my house and unloaded wasps into my
house the show would be off the air
don't don't say that don't he's he's
just making
they're like tim doesn't actually scare
cancellation put some wasps in his
building i don't know like oh there's
lots of everything
you weren't afraid of the stink bugs
i'm
i don't think that that could get you in
1984 the states knew your biggest fear
and for winston it was the fear of rats
and that's why they put a bucket with a
rat in it and it said the rat's going to
eat your face unless you obey the state
so
this is again the dangers of the track
trace and database society the society
that has the nsa snooping on every
aspect of our existence and it's not
out of the realm of possibility to
compare our current reality going
towards the 1984 well it was interesting
it brings up all the time which is on on
the money the vaccine database thing so
in april jeff science at the cdc
said that there was going to be no
federal vaccine database
jen saki said there was going to be no
federal vaccine credential and it
actually turns out that after the osha
mandate went through four federal
workers
this safety guidelines agency said
you know helped to help federal agencies
implement the vaccine mandate they said
and you will have to keep a database of
who's been vaccinated and who isn't and
the reasons for why the people didn't
get vaccinated specifically religious
exemptions so it turns out that the osha
mandate supersedes everything else for
federal workers and there will be
a bunch of different federal vaccine
databases at all for the employees at
all of these agencies and i and i think
unless
i think it's very likely it will happen
yes i think so
short of us actually speaking out and
people who like watch the show share
this show talk about these ideas stand
up for yourself and i think more and
more people are doing that if they don't
the supreme court may strike down
mandates for private companies but give
it five years and it will be commonplace
unless you speak up now charles murray
said that government is in an advanced
state of sclerosis where solutions are
outside the legislative process in the
courts
i i i think what we've experienced with
the new york times lawsuit is on point i
mean even if the supreme court were to
rule in my favor the new york times
would say trump judge right trump judge
who cares we don't care we're doing i
mean but does it matter to you
obviously winning against the new york
times is very important they defamed you
they caused you problems and money but
for the the snooty elites and their
ivory tower at their wine you'll never
convince them right literally jean dean
beckey had a glass of chardonnay
with his with his with his turtleneck
and blazer i want to shake
so there's a story in this book i i saw
dean beckham new york times pittsburgh i
was at one of literally the proverbial
seat at the table i was sitting next to
marty baron and dean beckett too and i
went to shake his hand
and he would think why would you want to
shake this horrible well you know maybe
there's a moment of humanity maybe maybe
he has a moment of levity no no he
whimpered and winced like a little
coward he wouldn't shake your hand he
wouldn't he turned around towards the
wall while holding i'm not making this
up a glass of wine wow
and i and i and at that moment i i i
realized that
yeah there's
you asked a question
it's not the satisfaction from the
verdict
the satisfaction comes
in the discovery part of litigation
where you're exposing them
the only thing that
for lack of a better word
communists
the only thing that communists fear
is being exposed
they do not fear the government they in
my experience they don't fear the courts
they don't fear the only thing that will
hold them accountable is
exposure and i think litigation does
that vis-a-vis the discovery process
when you open up their books when you
record them in depositions et cetera et
cetera also when you guys take a
microphone and put it up to their face
and they start running away
that's awesome do you ever notice that
they don't want to engage us in
conversation they want us to shut up i
want them to talk mm-hmm
interesting dichotomy right so so i i
see this with uh in the movie don't look
up have you seen it no is that netflix
movie yeah yeah one of the scenes it's
basically in the movie the republican
party is telling all of their you know
right-wing nut jobs not to look up at
the sky where the comet is coming to
destroy the planet so they don't and i'm
watching that and i'm like i think the
movie's funny it's poking fun at
everybody but the republicans the
conservatives are the meme of debate me
it's it's ben shapiro chasing after aoc
being like why won't you debate me while
the left says leave me alone i don't
want to talk to you if anyone is telling
you not to look up it's cnn right not
the right the rights demanding you look
up and the biden administration as well
that's saying that we need to stop this
information but they don't take any
questions from reporters and dr fauci
who today on the world economic forum
zoom call was literally saying we need
to fight disinformation from quote
medical health alongside of course xi
jinping who also was on the zoom
collision that goes well and they only i
don't they identify disinformation and
misinformation as anything that goes
along goes against whatever the current
narrative is which is
consistently changing
it goes back to the moment-to-moment
flexibility in the treatment effects we
talk about engaging in conversation i
again i i tell my staff
we welcome the inspectors that might
sound counterintuitive you're an
undercover operation you have to keep
secrets we don't keep many secrets tim i
i tell him everything you do is going to
be watched
um the new york times is required by
their ethical code to reach out for
comment they do do that via email but
they'll never print my response and when
i try to call them they hang up the
phone they hang up the phone they do
this clever thing where if your quote
hurts you it's in full right quote helps
you they'll snip it or paraphrase yeah
one one such comment was please respond
all these things so i quoted the judge
in the defamation lawsuit you the new
york times acted in disinformation and
deception i quoted a judge and the new
york times published when asked for a
comment mr o'keefe criticized the new
york times
well i didn't criticize the new york
times i was quoting a judicial authority
so that's that's false a statement
effect isn't it it is and we sued them
for defamation
so i mean so now we just put out our
quotes to the new york times to our
audience we just film myself yeah
emailing the new york times p i think
your audience wants solutions i i think
we know they they chop the quotes they
take it out of context solution i had uh
i had robert silverman who was this hack
reporter at uh daily beast he reached
out to me i think around
midnight eastern time and said uh he was
trying to get comment he said i'll give
you until 12 30 a.m to respond
this is how entitled some of them
you know like they're doing you the
favor they're writing a hit piece yeah
they contact you at the last hour
and then well most people are sleeping
at that time or
not checking their email and then uh
yeah and then your comment never makes
it into the published story andy i was
going to ask you how how do you deal
with the media coverage that you get
dealt with do you have any kind of legal
battles or what's your strategy when it
comes to dealing with the media that
attacks you
um
well
i've come to like james come to ignore
most of it uh unfortunately i don't have
the resources to do uh
lawsuits against everybody who defames
me and
the uh
in the u.s uh
death
proving definite defamation in a court
when your public figure is extremely
hard
and so
uh the point of these negative pieces is
to sabotage and ruin someone's
reputation and also to to demoralize
them and to take up their time i think
it's been more effective for me to
ignore most of it when it's really
egregious then i'll respond uh i think
like so recently in december a few weeks
ago
um i got an email
a night from a journalist asking me for
a comment about this federal lawsuit
that was filed against me for a
copyright violation that was the first
i've heard of it so these
two antifa activists
extremists in portland
sued me for retweeting their videos on
twitter okay completely frivolous
lawsuit
but the point wasn't necessarily about
winning it was about getting all of
these negative pieces out that said andy
no sued in federal court for stealing
journalist content
that's really damning for
i mean if you're a journalist your
reputation really matters by the way
this there's only as
uh as much as i say you know i ignore
this ignore that reputation at the end
of the day matters when you're a
journalist because your reputation is
your legitimacy that's how people know
that what you're reporting out is
accurate they can trust it
um and within less than two weeks the
the lawsuit was withdrawn and but so by
then you know
those left-wing uh media sites are not
going to write these new uh follow-up
stories about how this was a frivolous
lawsuit that was a waste of everyone's
time um but you know on the record now
people google me again in addition to
all the hit pieces before they see stuff
like this and now now it's forever that
even though the the lawsuit's gone they
can still say andy no has been sued for
stealing content in the past and it'll
be forever but i i do have to issue a
very strong correction you see
i stated on this show that that lawsuit
would be dismissed in summary judgment
and i was wrong they withdrew it because
it was a frivolous lawsuit so i didn't
even make it that far
but again it's the smear that counts and
that's what they were going for at least
in my opinion right the object of
persecution is to is persecution is to
break your will
you know that that's what they're trying
to do they're just trying to it's
usually these this litigation is an
exercise and just trying to
shut you up break your will bankrupt you
etc thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you